Lindsay is only 40.
she has a serious lung infection but
also suffers from multiple chronic
conditions and requires complex care
usually Lindsay is monitored remotely
but nine days ago she was rushed to
hospital as a category 1 emergency is
this the first time you've been in
hospital this winter
is
Pharmacy
Lindsay's consultant Dr Assad Ali says
more community support for patients like
Lindsay helps to ease the pressure
but the demand feels endless
how do you cope with an aging population
with complex medical problems on the
resources that the NHS has resources are
limited and nothing denying it and with
us all living longer and living with
more conditions means yes we do need
more resources to provide care but we
also need to do an appraisal of how best
we are utilizing our resources and
whether we can get more value
since the pandemic respiratory Services
have been flat out and there's no end in
sight
the last time I was here was back in
December at the height of flu season
every bed in every Bay was taken flu
cases have peaked but every bed in every
Bay is still taken they're still at 100
capacity the winter pressures don't
simply go away
and these pressures have long-term
impacts more than seven million people
are still waiting for elective care
taking the pocket where your pacemaker
is going to go a list that was too long
before the pandemic has only become
longer
Professor Kieran Patel is performing
surgery on an 88 year old patient a
little bit of pulling and pushing
she's having a pacemaker fitted it's
routine but life-changing operations
like these that are delayed when
hospitals are under severe pressure we
mustn't miss the opportunity that a
crisis affords to us and one of the
benefits is that it will force us to
transform the way in which we deliver
Health Care we'll need to get better at
knowing where our demand comes from what
it looks like so we need to move from
being a reactive Health Service to being
a responsive Health Service and
ultimately being a productive Health
Service
Lindsay hopes she can go home soon
her needs are long-term complicated and
challenging the same as the Health
Service she relies on
Ashish Joshi Sky News in Coventry